We are going back to the phones at (617) 830-4750
let's check in with Jeremy in Wisconsin. Jeremy
in Wisconsin on the six Oh eight number. Jeremy,
what's going on?
Hey David, how are you doing?
Good, how are you?
Well, good, good. So my question, um, sort
of relates to, I guess the ever increasing
role of international bodies and governance.
So seeing, I guess the example I'm thinking
about is the Amazon rainforest. How that obviously
if it's being destruct or it's being destroyed,
it has international consequences that affect
every nation. So I was wondering if you think
with things like that going on and kind of
globalization increasing general, do you think
international bodies will be more strong in
the future? And do you think they should go
in that route?
Well, I've said before that the um, the, the
idea that most of our major issues can be
solved within country borders is increasingly
an idea of the past. I mean, listen, the U
S can solve campaign finance internally. Sure.
But the U S is not going to be able to deal
with automation and outsourcing independently.
We're not going to be able to deal with climate
change independently. We're not gonna be able
to deal with pollution independently. Space
travel is something that is going to exceed
country lines. It's space exploration. So
the hyper nationalist mentality that other
peoples problems are only theirs and not ours.
And all of our problems are merely hours to
to solve. And we don't need anybody else.
It is such an antiquated and, and, and, and
uh, at this point, frankly bogus assertion
that, um, we are going to need to solve these
issues together. That's why that's another
reason, aside from sometimes the xenophobic
overtones of the hyper nationalists, it also
just doesn't work.
That's fair. Yeah. So I was wondering, I guess
you see the, I guess the results of the European
model, how there's been a little bit of pushback
to that with the rise of I guess nationalist
rhetoric and parts of the world. Do you think
America is going to go down the European model
and you're going to see more, I guess global
connections in terms of um, making policy?
Um, if we, if we elect the right people? Sure.
I mean, the current president is someone who
has resisted that and is more of a go it go
it alone sort of guy. And the effect that
it's having is that increasingly the United
States doesn't have a seat at the adult table
on more and more issues when it comes to a
global trade. Trump is just putting tariffs
on people and increasingly the, the, the sort
of outcast when it comes to climate change,
he's not even invited to a lot of important
summits and discussions. So I hope that that
happens, but it's going to depend on who we
elect.
Awesome. All right. Thank you David. Appreciate
you answering my question.
Alright, Jeremy, great to hear from you